The second most common misconception,
The second most common misconception
regarding Islam
today is that Muslims are called as
fundamentalist.
And we know
that during the Oklahoma bombing in US,
the moment the bombing was done, the
media went viral. Middle East
conspiracy, Middle East conspiracy
blaming Islam. Later on they realize it
was an American soldier who had done it
and then it comes as a news brief and
the media stops. They don't say that
what we did was wrong allegation against
Islam was wrong. They don't clarify it.
They talk about justice, Middle East
conspiracy, Middle East conspiracy. And
that's common.
They lay an allegation for days and
weeks. When they realize the truth, they
give a news brief. Okay, it was an
American soldier. No problem. American
doing no problem.
Oklahoma.
What is the meaning of the word
fundamentalist?
A fundamentalist means a person who
follows the fundamentals
of that particular subject or particular
field or particular area. For example,
if a person wants to be a fundamentalist
mathematician,
he should know, follow and practice the
fundamentals of mathematics.
Unless he is a fundamentalist
in the field of mathematics, he cannot
be a good mathematician. Similarly, if a
person wants to be
a fundamentalist doctor, medical doctor,
he should know, follow and practice the
fundamentals of medicine.
Unless he's a fundamentalist in the
field of medicine, he cannot be a good
doctor.
You can't paint all fundamentals with
the same brush that all are good, all or
all are bad. Depending in which field
the person is a fundamentalist, you have
to label him accordingly.
If you have
a fundamentalist thief
whose profession is to steal,
he's bad for the society. He's not a
good fundamentalist. On the other hand,
if you have a fundamentalist doctor
whose profession is to save hundreds and
thousands of human lives, he's good for
society. So you can't paint all
fundamentally with the same brush that
all are good or all are bad depending in
which field the person is a
fundamentalist. You have to label him
accordingly.
I Dr.
I am a fundamentalist Muslim and I am
proud to be a fundamentalist Muslim
because I know I follow and I practice
the fundamentals of Islam and I know
that there is not a single fundamental
of Islam which is against humanity as a
whole. There may be some teachings of
Islam which a non-Muslim may think it is
not correct. It's against humanity. But
the moment you give the reason and logic
regarding that fundamental of Islam
and explain to him in the correct
context, not what the media says, there
is not a single fundamental of Islam
which is against humanity as a whole.
Let us understand what is the definition
of fundamentalist according to different
dictionaries.
Webster dictionary says
that fundamentalism
was a movement that started in the early
part of the 20th century in USA in
America
when the American Protestants
they protested
against
modernism
and they said no the Bible is literally
the word of God. Every letter, every
word of the Bible is literally from
Almighty God. If someone can prove
that every letter, every word of the
Bible is from God, then this movement is
a good movement. But if someone can
prove that every letter, every word of
the Bible is not from Almighty God, then
this movement is not a good movement.
When we read the Oxford dictionary,
Oxford dictionary says
that fundamentalist
is a person who strictly adheres to the
ancient scriptures and fundamental
doctrines of any religion.
But when we read the latest edition of
Oxford dictionary, this is the old
edition.
The new edition of Oxford dictionary
says
you know after 911 there's an Oxford
dictionary before 911
and after 911 if you read in 2006 or 7
the revised Oxford dictionary says that
fundamentally there is a person who
strictly aderes to the ancient
scriptures or fundamental doctrines of
any religion especially Islam.
So especially Islam has been added
to the definition of the revised Oxford
dictionary.